I'm thirsty how about a refreshing drink
of coca-cola
my breath stinks how about a fresh piece
of orbit white gum I need some new
batteries for this remote how about some
Panasonic boy I sure love entertainment
magazines what's the best one probably
Entertainment Weekly right all these
people have come from all over the world
tonight just to be here don't just dump
them vote them in the wind it should be
magical it only happens once a year
Valentine's Day was directed by Garry
Marshall and stars mm-hmm what's that
it's called New Year's Eve you idiot
really
New Year's Eve is directed by Carrie
Marshall is Pawn Stars
a buttload of people it's like
Valentine's Day in fact it even started
out as a sequel to Valentine's Day and
then for some kind of reason they
changed it and now it's just its own
film again although it has stars from
Valentine's Day in it again it's another
film about some specific event or some
holiday of some kind and which
interlocking stories of romance and love
all happened on one night it's the same
it's the it's a gimmick movie it's a big
gimmick movie why why does this happen I
don't get it looks like a long list you
better get on it if you can make these
resolutions come true by midnight you
get these or tickets to a party you
called the right guy and won one night
can change everything there's no point
in going into some of the plots it's one
of those movies where there are so many
different stories that you just kind of
find the ones you like and you wait for
them to happen and you wait for the ones
that are not cool and boring to get out
of the ways you can get back to the
interesting stories see I like some of
these actors in this film so I didn't
hate this movie I didn't really dislike
it or loathe it or anything it's like oh
yeah Robert De Niro man you're awesome
Oh Halle Berry oh boy Halle Berry yeah
and then there are these other stories
that involve other actors who I'm not a
fan of Times Square tonight that's
highly dumb
there are good performances in this
movie there are a couple good stories in
this film that I liked I liked Michelle
Pfeiffer and Zac Efron in this movie I
thought those story was sweet and it was
interesting and it was different Hilary
Swank what are you doing in this movie I
don't get it why are so many actors who
won Academy Awards just doing that
cliche thing that actors who win Oscars
do Halle Berry won an Oscar than one she
do Catwoman would it what has she done
since her Oscar not much
Hilary Swank has won two Oscars she's
been in like straight-to-dvd thrillers
this year the resident I think it was
called what's going on here first maybe
delivered in the New Year it's 25 grand
oh it's on let's go honey nobody wins
with pregnant women fight
resolution number two Breakfast at
Tiffany's
nevertheless there are good things in
this movie there are certain stories I
was interested in I think that Ashton
Kutcher is a good actor I've seen him in
performances where he's not good but
lately he seems to be improving and this
year I like no strings attached I
thought that movie was directed with a
lot more professionalism and given a lot
more respect for that kind of source
material they had Natalie Portman in it
and I thought Ashton was very good in
the film but for the most part this
movie is just a giant cliched product
placement and that's really honestly my
biggest problem with this movie the
product placement is insane what because
it's New Year's Eve if you want another
shot at it just fooling around I like
waiting around like every other shot is
blue and every other shot has somebody
wearing a Nivea hat or a giant Nivea
sign of some kind but the worst product
placement in this movie is the fact that
in many times square scenes in the
background there is a giant poster for
Sherlock Holmes - in fact the final shot
of the movie pans up the whole panning
up shot on the entire right side of the
screen and there's Sherlock Holmes -
poster guess what it comes out next
weekend this film is like a giant
product placement for Sherlock Holmes -
it's shameless
we've gotta do something to get you out
of your New Year's Eve fuck we could
have our own party there are good
performances here there are interesting
stories here there are some really bad
ones and there are just a rolling
moments of stupidity
but it's not as bad I think as people
are saying it is I'm gonna give New
Year's Eve a see did you see Valentine's
Day did you like Valentine's Day do you
plan on seeing New Year's Eve what do
you think let me know in stuckman square
if you're sick of movies like this let
me know - it was like this review you
can subscribe to my channel or gets
stuck mine eyes